[Music]
on this monday night the countdown to
ontario's
lockdown strict new protocols are coming
to the entire province
this is an extremely serious threat the
backlash from canada's capital city
the uk in isolation no one's allowed in
or out it might be a little too late
canada's plan to avoid a mutated strain
of covet 19
accommodating adults the pediatric icu
being forced to pivot
and the difficulties for doctors and
nurses
it's gut wrenching plus underpants a
nerve agent
and a russian spy uncovering the plot to
poison a kremlin critic
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
as global news first reported last night
ontario is going into lockdown
28 days for most of the province 14 days
for the north
but it doesn't go into effect until
boxing day ontario has one of the worst
coveted 19 caseloads in canada
for the past week more than 2 000 new
cases a day
but in the nation's capital where case
numbers have already dropped off
there's a feeling there's no reward for
abiding by the rules
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
this is the problem ontarians still
interacting with too many people outside
their homes
shopping at work and in other gatherings
it's led to a looming crisis for
hospital beds especially in southern
ontario
and to a rising death toll once again in
long-term care homes
so a lockdown is coming the day after
christmas
make no mistake thousands of lives
are at stake right now if we fail to
take action now
the consequences could be catastrophic
on december 26th ontario's limited
lockdown goes province wide
non-essential businesses will close to
in-person retail till january 9th in
northern ontario
until january 23 in southern ontario
schools will reopen later
in northern ontario and for elementary
schools in southern ontario
on january 11th high schools in the
south will do remote learning till the
25th
child care and grocery stores can remain
open restaurants and bars can open for
takeout
hardware and pet stores can stay open
for curbside pickup
one administrator drove home the urgency
for his hospital network in toronto and
brampton
i can tell you that the surgeries that
we are canceling
are people that have been waiting for
certain surgeries in pain
for two to three years indeed the stress
on hospitals is increasing
latest modeling shows ontario's icu
occupancy will be over 300 beds within
days
and could rise to over 600 or higher in
january
potentially overwhelming some hospitals
capacity to care for serious illnesses
and accident victims we're in a very
very challenging and precarious
situation
public health officials are fully behind
a stringent lockdown
we don't believe anything less than four
weeks will be effective and longer
durations will be more effective
regions like ottawa are doing better
than toronto and some there
aren't happy with a full lockdown it's a
little bit of a
kick in the gut i would say we've been
doing really hard work here in ottawa to
get our numbers in line
the business community along with the
residential community as dr etches
pointed out
have been working very very hard
following the rules
only to be surprised as i said
blindsided by the province
but if ottawa stays open the province
fears more people would stream in
from quebec for example nothing against
quebecers i love the quebecers but
they're
they'll come over in droves we're acting
we're being decisive and i'll always
listen to our health experts
even before the lockdown the message
from the province is if you can
just stay home it will reduce the number
of coveted cases
sooner eric sorensen global news
canada has joined the list of countries
now banning travel from the united
kingdom to keep a new strain of kova 19
out it's more contagious and is
responsible for a wave of new cases in
the uk
now there's no evidence that it has
reached this country but in europe there
is concern because
people have been traveling here's
crystal command sing on the world
strategy
to isolate britain no entry
that's the message being sent to britain
truckers who normally haul goods between
england and france have been shut out i
come
twice a month to england and go back
i take freight to england and freight to
poland but
such situation is very stupid a new
strain of the coronavirus is spreading
in the uk
and other countries fear it'll be
imported
more than 40 countries have implemented
some type of travel ban
canada suspended flights until at least
wednesday
in reality at this point it might be
a little too late right this variant was
first identified in september
and there was some travel between
individuals in the uk to other countries
it has been identified in very
limited numbers in countries including
australia
and iceland however it is spreading
fastest
in england the new variant is out of
control and we need to bring it under
control
another lockdown was imposed sunday on
roughly 21 million people in london
southeast england and wales the world
health organization
is urging calm so this situation is not
in that sense out of control but it
cannot be left
uh to its own devices either personal
behavior or the virus itself as the
as we learn more about the virus we'll
learn more about
how how how it may replace other strains
and that as i said has happened before
this mutation
like the others does not appear to cause
more severe illness
and vaccines should still be effective
crystal gomansing global news london the
alberta government is asking all
travelers who have arrived from the uk
in the past 14 days to get tested for
coven 19.
those travelers are also required to
quarantine for a full
14-day period they're not eligible for
the border pilot program that reduces
quarantine time anyone who has arrived
from the uk
will be contacted by alberta health
services to book a test
coveted patients are flooding into
alberta hospitals in edmonton
the situation is so critical the
children's hospital
is now preparing to care for critically
ill adults
as heather york's west explains medical
experts say wait for it
the worst of this wave is still weeks
away
when brittany bodner heard adult covet
patients were being moved to
edmonton-stoller
children's hospital she says her heart
dropped
any time that i have a moment to reflect
on our experience i'm
quite honestly brought to tears i
couldn't be at her bedside that was
honestly it was devastating
vodner's baby daughter sage spent four
months in icu last spring following
three heart surgeries
covid protocols during the first wave
meant only one parent could be in the
room at a time
with no place to sleep alberta's second
wave surge
means those policies are now back again
as the demand for the icu bets are
increased
we are being called on to give up some
of that space so that the adult
uh care teams can move into there with
covet patient numbers swelling alberta
health services is scrambling to expand
capacity in the province's hospitals
the problem is people are people and
everybody wants to get back to their
life
and right now we're paying a price for
that how it started
how it's going photos shared by dr
marklin painting a pretty clear picture
of how many ventilators are now being
used by covet patients
at the royal alexandra hospital there
are presenters of those people who go on
ventilators that
end up never coming off people get
initially better and then they get this
secondary
injury that slowly turns their lungs
into concrete and it's like concrete
slowly setting
and those people become dependent on the
ventilator to the point where we
actually can't push the air in out of
them anymore
personally almost every single day last
week i had at least one if not two or
three deaths
it's incredible how much death we're
seeing with no choice right now but to
carry on
knowing that any kind of relief is still
at best
weeks away heather urex west global news
calgary the nhl says it will return to
the ice in january
the league and the players association
agreed to a 56-game season
that includes an all-canadian north
division but all five provinces need to
sign on
and today health leaders in bc gave no
assurance
this is an intense time the nhl has
provided
what they're proposing to do and now
we'll take a look at it mostly
all of us need to be on the same page
about how we're going to
manage this we've given options back to
the nhl and we'll be looking at things
again
dr bonnie henry says bc is not the only
province that has expressed concerns
over the league's proposal
in a statement the nhl says it is aware
of the challenges ahead and will
continue to prioritize the health and
safety of participants
and communities undercover work to
uncover the truth
coming up russia's opposition leader
gets to the bottom
of how he was poisoned plus roaring with
lava
the eruption and earthquakes in hawaii
u.s president donald trump is rarely
seen in public anymore despite thousands
of americans dying from coven 19 every
day
in just 30 days though joe biden will be
inaugurated as the next president of the
united states
tonight our jackson proskow looks at
trump's final and desperate days in
office
still inside the white house but rarely
seen in public
president donald trump has spent his
final weeks scheming to overturn the
election he lost
we have uncovered a voter fraud the
greatest voter fraud in history
those baseless claims have met fierce
pushback
to this point i have not seen a reason
to appoint a
special counsel from outgoing attorney
general bill barr
who shot down the suggestion from some
trump advisers
that the federal government sees voting
machines from the states
i see no basis now for
seizing machines but trump is still
fixated on the election
reportedly asking advisers whether he
could use the u.s military to re-run the
vote in key swing states
all the while absent from the real
crises facing the u.s
like a large-scale cyber attack on u.s
government infrastructure linked to
russia
an economy wrecked by more job losses
and already high unemployment
and a surge in covet 19 cases with
thousands of deaths every single day
and a growing shortage of hospital beds
in the hardest hit states
it's extremely bad there's no you know
questioning how bad it is anymore
president-elect joe biden received his
coronavirus vaccination on monday
and urged americans to hold out hope
that things will improve
this is great hope i'm doing this to
demonstrate
that people should be prepared when it's
available to take the vaccine the
challenges facing the u.s will only grow
worse between now and biden's january
inauguration
a period marked by an unprecedented
absence of leadership
much like trump the white house
coronavirus task force has also largely
disappeared from public
view and just a few days before
christmas there has been no coordinated
federal guidance about avoiding travel
or other potentially risky situations
robin
jackson prosco in washington thanks
jackson russian
opposition leader alexei navalny has
duped a spy into revealing
how he was poisoned it turns out the
deadly nerve agent novochuck was applied
to navalny's
underwear he wore the poison pants the
day he boarded a flight to moscow and
fell violently ill
that was back in august as part of a
bellingcat investigation one of the
operatives
allegedly involved in the assassination
attempt revealed the plot when navalny
phoned him and tricked him into thinking
he was someone else
russia's federal security service calls
navalny's actions
a provocation a british court has found
two men guilty of manslaughter in the
deaths of 39 vietnamese migrants who
suffocated in the back of a container
truck
the horrific discovery was made in
october 2019.
the victims between the ages of 15 to 44
were smuggled into the uk from france
inside a sealed trailer that heated up
to 38.5 degrees
some called family back in vietnam to
plead for help as they ran out of oxygen
george nica from romania was an
organizer of the smuggling operation
the driver eamon harrison from northern
ireland claimed he didn't know
there were people in the trailer both
will be sentenced in the new year
still ahead after years of promises why
are clean water projects still a
struggle for several first nations
you're watching global national
[Music]
the lava port of the kilauea volcano
following about
seven earthquakes on hawaii's big island
a 4.4 magnitude earthquake then followed
the eruption
it has now stabilized with no reports of
significant damage or anyone being hurt
in 2018 a major eruption forced many
residents to leave their homes
about 700 homes were destroyed kilauea
is the most active of hawaii's
five volcanoes members of the
neshkandiga first nation
are finally home after a 60-day
evacuation
but their water is still not safe enough
to drink the community's water was shut
off in the fall
after an oily sheen was discovered in
the reservoir
upgrades to the water system were
scheduled to be completed in 2018
but residents are still waiting nearly
three years later
and now an investigation by global news
aptn
and the institute for investigative
journalism has found neshcandiga
isn't the only first nation to encounter
issues with contractors
catherine ward reports
when you arrive in nescantiga first
nation in northern ontario
you can't help but notice the signs the
community here has been under a boil
water advisory since 1995
the longest in canada my daughter
she's 23 years old and never had clean
drinking water
kingdom construction limited was hired
in 2017 to construct the upgrade to the
community's water treatment plant
and distribution system the goal make
clean drinking water available
by may 2018. however after an
eight-month delay
niskantika terminated the contract the
federal government has invested 16.4
million dollars to date
but residents still cannot drink the
water you hate to see
your relatives your children your future
living in this condition and there seems
to be no end
in the fall niskantika leaders called
for an investigation into the business
practices of the contractors
and engineering firms that worked on
their water system
global news and its partners have spoken
to four other first nations
who allege kingdom construction
delivered work that was incomplete
late and over budget indigenous services
canada
acknowledges issues with the conduct of
some firms
but wouldn't address specific
allegations against any one company
the scandiga is a particularly acute
example of that
is there are issues with third-party
contractors um and
and and spotty records and sharp
practices and as you see across canada
you have contractors that uh that don't
necessarily behave well
this is ryan to babarang's community
with seeing first nation along georgian
bay
kingdom construction was also hired to
build a water treatment plant here in
2010.
it was pretty early on that we received
a
request for an extra do you remember the
cost the ask
was over a million dollars tababarang
says even though the project was
finished in 2012 it was delayed by 11
months
and over budget in a phone interview
with aptn's melissa ridgeon
the president of kingdom construction
said his company wanted to avoid
first nations projects in the future we
just don't want to go back to native
works
anymore and the reason is it's just too
complicated there's too much politics
too many players
everybody's trying to cover their bots
and you know it's just it's very complex
landry later apologized for the language
he used
and acknowledged that it was culturally
insensitive
kingdom denies any allegations that its
work did not meet the highest standards
including in iscantica adding that in
any project there can be unforeseen
expenses
and potential delays and that additional
costs are always approved
by the design engineers based on the
facts on the ground
catherine ward global news
up next the doctor who has tackled
canada's health crisis
as well as his own
an off-duty rescue worker in thailand
was called into action to revive a baby
elephant
a motorcycle knocked the animal to the
ground and it was losing consciousness
but after several minutes of cpr the
baby managed to stand up on its own
it eventually made its way back to an
adult elephant presumed to be its mother
throughout this pandemic health care
workers have been putting their own
lives on the line
one of them is dr michael gardum he's
been through many health emergencies
but nothing as extensive and dangerous
as covid19
it's a lot of pressure to be responsible
for the health of the public
and then dr gardem had his own scare as
jeff semple reports
he had to make a major decision
as covid 19 cases climb again staff on
the front lines are worrying less about
infection than exhaustion
each day brings a new potential covet
outbreak
dr michael gardum is no stranger to the
pressures of a public health emergency
garden was on the front lines of the
sars outbreak in 2003
h1n1 in 2009 and canada's response to
ebola in 2014.
if there's lots of virus in the room got
caught with their pants certainly if you
have a lot of cases of flu
out there he's given countless media
interviews
providing a calm hand in the storm
there was so much fear and when you're
the person who's advising on what to do
and you're in all those meetings and
you're speaking to people in the media
and you're getting hit with these waves
of fear
that is exhausting so this is our our
kova 19 tile
in the first wave of covid19 gardum was
chief of staff
at this toronto hospital during a shift
back in may
he suddenly felt a pain in his chest
as a physician you spend your first 10
minutes running through a list of things
that this could be in your head
and then thinking this can't possibly be
cardiac but as he stumbled
into the emergency ward he realized
that's exactly what it was
gardem was having a heart attack caused
by a blockage in his left anterior
descending artery
morbidly nicknamed the widow maker talk
about access to health care right you
know i had a heart attack
in the hospital they treated me
extremely quickly if it would have
happened the day before i i wouldn't be
here
now seven months later gaurdam a former
marathoner has made a full
recovery and a life change
in october he moved out of the big city
to the ocean
on prince edward island the
level of chronic stress and anxiety
which i think was
compounded with the pandemic
that was like a major wake-up call for
me he's still working full-time
often remotely and at 56 says he has no
interest in retiring
and this is no time to back away from a
fight
i know that uh there's been some
pushback about using war analogies you
know the way i look at it is
that it's kind of like we're in 1944
right now
you sort of think that there you can see
an end to this
but it's not going to happen tomorrow
and we've got months of slog to get
there
and you can't stop if you stop
you're going to lose all of the things
that you fought so hard to win
jeff semple global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with a once in a
lifetime celestial event
the planets jupiter and saturn have been
closely aligning to form a great
conjunction
event not seen in nearly 800 years
together they form what might appear to
be a bright christmas star
if you're lucky to have a clear sky
where you are tonight you might see it
for yourself
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you